a spokesman for the u.s led coalition in
iraq says the al-assad air base was
attacked by
14 rockets with two american troops
sustaining minor injuries
the syrian democratic forces say their
u.s backed troops assisted americans in
foiling
a drone attack on a base housing
coalition members in eastern syria
the statement says there were no damages
a british group says the drones took off
from areas controlled by iran-backed
fighters
regional officials in northern
afghanistan say they have recaptured
government buildings in a provincial
capital
after taliban fighters stormed them
overnight taking over the police
headquarters and sparking panic among
residents
officials said airstrikes were being
carried out and special forces had been
deployed
to push the taliban fighters back the
islamic
islamic insurgents have been advancing
for weeks
as the u.s pulls its troops out of
afghanistan president biden says he will
address the situation in afghanistan
tomorrow when we